even as covenanting cases continue to
break records the cdc is standing firm
on its guidance on isolation and testing
on tuesday it said people can use a
rapid test around day five of isolation
if they have access to one if that test
is positive people should stay home for
those extra five days um and if that
test is negative people really do need
to understand that they must continue to
wear their mask for those uh extra five
days the problem americans are still
facing however is actually getting a
test the country is seeing a nationwide
shortage but the biden administration
says a website where people can order a
free test should be up later this month
the country broke a global record for
cases with more than one million
reported in a single day on monday the
surge is so high i had so many friends
and family that i heard over the break
that got sick and they didn't even know
it it doesn't feel safe anymore a little
more concerned yeah
more precautions they have to take now
hospitalizations were up about 63
percent compared to last week while
deaths rose about five percent cdc
director dr richelle wallensky says
omicron now makes up about 95 percent of
cases in the u.s and while dr anthony
fauci says more focus could be put on
hospitalizations wallenski says case
numbers are still relevant case counts
are often a leading indicator because
the severity of disease and healthcare
infrastructure might lag behind what is
happening in case counts the surge is
also impacting schools chicago's public
school teachers voted to switch to
remote learning tuesday on wednesday
city officials canceled classes
altogether there is no basis in the data
the science or common sense for us to
shut an entire system down when we can
surgically do this at a school level
where needed
the cdc gave the green light wednesday
for the pfizer booster for those age 12
to 15. that's in addition to
recommending a booster at five months
instead of six and an additional dose
for certain immunocompromised children
between five and eleven years old as
more americans get their third shots the
white house says there are no plans to
change the definition of fully
vaccinated but the cdc still encourages
people to stay up to date with their
vaccines
sean previl global news